Welcome to PyMOL 101 with Molecular Memory!
I’m KP and in this lesson, we’ll learn
to use color in PyMOL.
By default, PyMOL applies a version of CPK
coloring, where oxygen is red, nitrogen is
blue, sulfur is yellow, and phosphorous is
orange.
Sometimes it’s useful to override this,
especially to look at the overall structure
of a macromolecule.
we’ll also explore transparency in this
lesson to make our colors shine through.
Let’s do this.
Phosphofructokinase—PFK for short—is a
protein that speeds up a chemical reaction,
so it’s an enzyme.
It’s the third enzyme in glycolysis, a 10-step
pathway that breaks down the carbohydrate
glucose.
PFK is cool because it can interconvert between
two shapes, or conformations, depending on
chemical signals in the cell.
One conformation speeds up the reaction more
efficiently than the other, allowing this
enzyme to act as a main control valve determining
whether we break down carbohydrates for energy,
otherwise we can store them or make bigger
molecules in biosynthesis.
Load the biological assembly of 6pfk in PyMOL.
File, get PDB, 6pfk, assembly 1.
Display the sequence, and let’s scroll through
it.
We see breaks in the amino acid sequences,
and this is because PFK has four chains of
amino acids.
It’s a multichain protein with quaternary
structure.
This particular structure is the less active
form of PFK, and each subunit is bound to
PGA.
We’re not focusing on water molecules in
this lesson, so let’s hide them: H, waters.
Let’s color the chains to see them easily.
In the names panel, click the C button for
color.
Choose by chain, and then the top choice.
This star (*) elem C means we’re applying
CPK coloring to show the elements.
Now, in the sequence, select a PGA and zoom
in on it using the A button.
Notice the CPK coloring—this orange atom
here is phosphorous.
Zoom back out using 6pfk to view the whole
protein.
And I don’t want this selection to get in
the way of my next steps, so I’m gonna go
ahead and use the A button to delete it.
Let’s add a surface rendering.
Names panel, S button, surface - to layer
a surface rendering on top of the default
cartoon.
With CPK coloring applied, the surface is
busy, detracting from the chain coloring.
Surface may be a rendering where CPK coloring
is less preferred.
Click C, by chain, and select the last choice.
This colors each chain a solid color, without
CPK coloring.
Now we’re really highlighting the four chains
of PFK.
Now, let’s color by ss – secondary structure.
This highlights alpha helices, beta sheets,
and areas of the protein without a defined
secondary structure called loops.
But this rendering isn’t super useful with
the protein shown as surface, since the bumpy
surface obscures the secondary structure.
Hide the surface to reveal the cartoon beneath.
Now, that’s cool, and very useful.
What if we want to show both the secondary
structure /and/ the protein’s surface?
We can make the surface semi-transparent to
achieve this!
Add the surface back, using the show button.
Now, use the dropdown setting menu, find transparency,
surface, and let’s go with 60%.
Now, let’s make the surface stand out a
little better by changing its color.
C, by rep, surface, and let’s choose one
of these grays.
The secondary structure of the multicolor
cartoon we see beneath is determined by hydrogen
bonds between the amino acid backbone atoms,
which are called “main chain” in the PyMOL
menus.
But, we can also see the bumpiness of the
surface—that where amino acid side chains
are taking up space.
Let’s add these side chains.
Show, side chains, sticks.
And we can now see how these fit into the
surface.
The sticks are kind of thick and the rendering
is looking much too busy, so let’s hide
the sticks.
Now, let’s show lines instead and color
them with CPK coloring.
Now choose C, by element.
Each of these choices, and there are several
sets of them, colors by a modified CPK coloring,
where we choose the carbon color.
Carbons don’t have to be gray or black,
as they are in traditional CPK coloring.
Choose either cyan or white carbons from this
first set.
Cyan is a light blue green color that’s
relatively colorblind friendly.
When choosing the carbon color, it’s important
to think about the atoms in your structure.
When modeling proteins, we want to avoid colors
that are similar to the blue, red, and yellow
of CPK nitrogen, oxygen, and sulfur, because
we find these in amino acids.
Next we’ll play with the rendering of PGA.
But before we do that: a quick terminology
break.
We mentioned this is the less active conformation,
and PGA helps force the enzyme into this shape
because it’s an inhibitor.
Inhibitors slow or stop an enzyme from performing
a chemical reaction.
And anything that binds a protein can be generally
called a ligand, or lie-gand.
So, the inhibitor is a ligand.
Let’s try a new representation, to gain
a sense of where the ligands bind to the protein.
Using the sequence, select all four PGAs.
You can click on each individually in the
sequence, or click and drag over all four
at once.
The letters Sele come up in the names panel,
and next to that, let’s click, A, rename,
and we’ll call these ligands.
Now, show these as spheres.
Remember, “show as” changes the rendering
completely.
By contrast, plain old “show” lets you
layer representations on top of each other,
like we have with the stick and surface views
of the protein.
Cool, the location of the ligands is easy
to see now.
Let’s make their carbon atoms contrast the
protein a bit more, but still color by element.
C, by element, and choose one with green carbon
atoms.
The cartoon is another rendering that can
have transparency.
Let’s hide the lines and surface, go back
to cartoon rendering, and apply transparency.
This is a good time to use “show as”.
6pfk, show as, cartoon.
Notice this command cleared both the lines
and the surface.
But it also cleared the sphere rendering of
the ligand.
No problem, that’s why we made a selection
for the object we’re focusing on.
Next to ligands, S, spheres to get the ligand
back.
Now, Setting dropdown, Transparency, Cartoon,
50%.
And we can now see both secondary structure
and the location of the ligand.
The type of rendering you choose for a model
really depends on what you want to show the
viewer.
It’s a good idea to think about this before
starting the model, but don’t be afraid
to play around with the renderings to find
the best display possible.
Thanks for watching this episode of PyMOL
101.
Next time, we’ll refresh and build on techniques
from Lesson 2 to show and label a binding
site on PFK.
If you’re enjoying this series, like, subscribe,
and if there’s anything specific you’d
like to learn, let me know in the comments!